device
focusrite yes
hello
yeah
yes but
this is my headset or
i believe we are we are good i believe
we're good
question is can you hear both of us
hello
oh yes okay
is it this that we can hear
okay okay okay
okay yeah we can definitely hear both of
us we did it we did it finally hello
everyone
they can hear us that okay hello
everyone this is allie welcome ally
what's up guys we live together
and she has an awesome new channel that
i was gonna bring up to show everybody
and then we couldn't hear us
and that's what happened
okay
i could just click here nope that is
marvel entertainment done on me
i wish it was you
what if
i know right that's me that is you how
do i
echo oh no that's not it
that's still not it
i figured it out now
this is alex
ally
this is her
look
her
she now has this channel called marvel
minute news and you all should go
subscribe to her right now
wait hold on yeah that's her
left ear only what
he's not the first person that said that
left ear i don't
i don't know how to fix that
echo from the
headphones oh that might actually bend
that no it wasn't yeah it was this i
don't know how to fix the left ear only
thing unfortunately
that that i really don't know how to fix
um
let's see what we got
here properties lady warren
this is lady warren
um
it all seems to be fun i don't know why
it's only in one ear that's weird
but if i do it in another way
then we're not gonna be able to hear
all right we're gonna have to we're
gonna oh you can hear but all right so
yeah
mr anderson what is up what is going on
let's actually just drop the link in the
chat
[Music]
oh i forgot you have to do this stupid
stuff
here you go guys this is
this is allie's channel marvel minute
news
she does quick straight to the point
news unlike me who dives deep down into
everything
and can talk for hours upon hours about
one single subject whereas she'll tell
you in a minute
so if you want straight to the point
news
there you go that's the channel for you
and let's see we got probably about
let's say 20 minutes until hawkeye
starts
um she's not my girlfriend or my sister
we just sort of sister sort of my sister
because if you consider it if you
consider chris my brother
then she's my sister
there you go mr anderson is in the chat
he's been talking i'm sure he's doing a
lot of work behind the scenes he's doing
a lot right now
sounding clear okay thank you matthew
appreciate that looks like we're doing
we're doing all right right now so what
is everybody expecting
of hawkeye dopestar gaming huge
spider-man fan i don't know if you can
tell i am we are we are too yeah yeah
wait who has oh chris has the spiderman
chair
gotcha gotcha gotcha i have captain
america hey look it's teague
what up team stop by to say hi
to ally hello no love for me
what's up fart shot hey thanks so much
do you think watch could be one of the
end of spider-man homecoming that tony
wears
yeah i think so
i really do i really think so
that's something i'm i'm hoping we find
out sooner than later like so we can
just kind of know like what's the
reasoning behind everything and who does
echo work for she was introduced at the
end
i know alex thinks
aly thinks kingpin
he's gonna mess me up
uh and i'm thinking
kingpin too uh
well
two things not my girlfriend but three
she's not photoshopped she's
photoshopped i'm here she's here
but thank you i'm alive the comic
emperor for
that's felix oh it's a cat trying to
break through what hey look it's
forsaken
hi first thing again what's up dude
who's wes where's wes
west nemo
oh is he in here it's um nemo what's up
wes how's it going man
what is going on glad to see you stopped
by
i'm seeing a lot of kingpins in the chat
you want to change your answer ally from
kingpin or no
100 she's oh no
you can count on me oh oh
we're theorizing here it's not said it's
not set in stone this is like a
guarantee thing where it is if i say it
then it will be just put it out into the
universe
all right all right
just taking a side of my homies right
guys
everybody seems to think
everybody seems to think it's kingpin i
i think it's kingpin my whole breakdown
last time was basically like hey look
here's how everything connects to
kingpin
so
i told him chris just touched ally what
did you say it was the face
we have the footage we have the footage
hey bro what do you think for who
echo works kingpin i think
i think that's uh
i think that's the general consensus
right now hello from america hello also
from america
hello from malaysia malaysia hello from
america
20 minutes ago uh i'd probably say like
15 they usually start early let's check
this out so i don't know if you guys
noticed
disney did this thing where it's like
i used to be able to show it i used to
be able to show the footage on my screen
but now i can't
because they
i don't know what they did they made it
to where you can't like stream it or
show it or you can't even take
screenshots of it which is kind of hard
to like do a breakdown edit on
uh steven that is actually a very good
question thanks for the super chat the
bigger question is
does daredevil show up in a post credit
scene
you know it's really hard to compare
um i was going to say what if doesn't
have a post credit scene and it's really
hard to compare the two because
obviously what if was like a one-off
thing
what if didn't have the post-credits
scene but
i'm thinking this one will because the
others kind of did right so i'm thinking
you're out of the frame now
um what's up dallas manias
uh not my lady just my one of my best
friends uh her and her husband live with
me everybody knows chris i'm pretty sure
this is chris's wife
and i brought her on because she just
started a new channel
that chris and i are helping her with
and this is it right here
check that out
she's doing awesome so far
news marvel minute news she'll give you
the info really really quick
that's a good question brian comstock do
you we see val you know
she's got to be behind doing a lot of
stuff maybe because of elena right we
still don't know if yolanda's going to
be as feeling is going to be popping up
in all of this right so
who who knows right we'll have to take a
look at that let me see this
i forgot to do one thing real quick
one second guys i will get to the super
chats
i just have to pull them up
so i don't miss any i also gotta do this
let's make sure we're making some money
here
there we go all right
super chat super chat supers
[Music]
did i just receive that i think i just
received that
there goes somewhere
uh but thank you for that superset
jealous dallas uh this has to move
because like
i can't see anything
there we go that should work all the
same
okay um
ev bull
why was ant-man mentioned in the first
episode in the theater and not
spider-man
well
i don't know
like to just be str i mean i know why
spider-man wasn't mentioned because
you know he's kind of
he wasn't around yet right the first
avengers happened which the play is
the play musical was based off of was uh
based from the very first avengers film
and
neither ant-man or spider-man were
around then so why i have zero idea i
don't know why they put ant-man in there
that's gonna be something um
that's gonna be something that we're
gonna have to like get in like a post
post series question somebody's going to
talk to like a writer or a producer or
something like that and that's where
we're going to get the uh
oh that's
that's nice
um
farshad
bro what is your favorite disney plus
series at loki i'm
i like boku the best did you like one
division the best or loki i preferred
loki over one division yeah i love both
but loki is definitely my favorite so
far like
by far loki is my favorite tell mr
anderson
tell her tell her tell her tell her
what
no only fancy hair
you guys are my only viewers probably
bank though little we have she has a
little bit more respect than that
for herself what's up michael johnson
how's it going
when's it coming out
probably 10 minutes i would say 10
pounds
i say 6.
is this why you're here just to like
contradict everything just go against
everything i say
i think king finn was with what you said
it's true it's only because i'm right
yeah i don't guys i don't know
i don't know what the audio is some
people are saying it's fine some people
are saying it's not i'm going to check
the properties again right here
um
audio input capture let's go properties
i'm not seeing
i'm not
i'm not seeing how it's you know that's
the weirdest thing i'm not seeing how
it's off i just i just don't know i'm
sorry wait
does
talk
come in one ear and i go on the other is
that
what if i do this
okay
what about now
everybody said
that's all okay i get it i get it can we
can we uh can we
can we hear me now
hello hello
all right all right can't hear can't
hear
i think i'm understanding okay
everybody's in it i know there's a
little bit of a delay
here hold on this is why i always bring
it up
there we go
[Music]
is it in both ears or is it just in one
that's what i was trying to fix
thank you aj aj aj thank you so much
thank you so much
mr anderson and aj can you hear from
both ears
some people can hear only left
i think a lot of people's headsets are
broken
wes obs
advance audio properties select mono
okay this is why wes is here and thanks
for the super chat to get us there okay
audio advanced audio properties
uh
select mono
now
what about now
thank you aj audio only and left ear
what about now did we fix it or is there
no audio at all
two here so p this is so great it's good
now okay wait wait is it good now
hello
fixed i'm seeing fixed can't hear you at
all big fan thank you cooking for
parents
would you cook for children one day
just just curious
yes good good yes the audio is good
fixed w i we did it all right thank you
wes
everybody shout out to wes nemo because
he
he did it okay fix we got it
we got it we got it we got it oh wes
hey iman amon i'm on sorry if i didn't
pronounce that right amman tandon
love to back to india back to you
tanish thank you
game day here we go is it out yet let's
uh
two minutes i'll give it two minutes
so we're gonna try something different
today
because last time i couldn't
show you guys the screen because
disney's got smart
and anytime i try to show it it just
shows a black screen so this time we're
just going to watch it on my ipad
and i'm just going to turn the ipad
every now and then
and that's all that's all i pretty much
that's all i pretty much got for you
guys all right we fixed that
it's so funny that it was like
in stereos and left and right because i
have one mic i don't
i don't know how that even works but
anyway do i think kingpin is the main
villain speed pedro pedro like that yes
uh i do think so
gamer extinction free fire did i book my
tickets for now at home yes it took us
four hours
we were up very late she fell asleep
during the process but we got the
tickets we did we did we did and it was
a lot of fun but uh a lot of fun i'm
being sarcastic
it was an experience how about that it
was an experience we uh
we did what we had to do we did what we
had to do we got spider-man tickets for
the very first day
and uh can't go back now
that those times were those
it was taken away from my life and i'll
never get them back but that's what we
do for spider-man right worth it that is
what we do for spider-man
mr anderson's other one at somebody and
now i can't see the comment oh man
i want to know what was funny oh you
should tell everyone to stop being sims
that's funny
i don't know if you can blame them
though
for people wondering who she is
there there she is go to that youtube
channel boom
there she is help her out she's just
getting started i'm trying to help her
out
follow me in my journey
no i don't know if that's real people be
trolling i'm watching oh my gosh you're
right everyone all right guys
so here's what we're gonna do
i have
do you have your your your pardon yeah
okay
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
start this and then i'm gonna just
casually
show you the screen that's all i can do
right now
um
we have to hold on
you get ready to hit that as i bring
something up okay hold on
because i have to get a
this one's shorter it's only 44 minutes
no that's about how much oh yeah
all right we're about to start
in five
four
three
two
one
that sound
we're moving
uh
we're recapping i don't see any i don't
hear anything oh i start
there we go
cool there we are
cool and i got this and i'm gonna do
this
uh
there you go
we are moving
why do you do that
oh it's turned up on wow there we go
we're recapping right now
i love the tracksuit bandit because i
bro bro i found her bro i found her
i same here mr anderson i need
monogrammed butterscotch
that's like cosmic on them
it is out we are moving
it is the beginning screens that we have
right there
we are chilling let's do this
i'm opening this up because i need it
but i don't want 300 milligrams of
caffeine for
oh can you have that water too please
yes
oh really midnight girl 10. i'm glad you
like the show i'm hoping it gets like
insanely good right now
not that i didn't enjoy it before but i
think like with echo and
some villains i think it's about to go
crazy
um
oh this is going to be about echo
maybe not can they bring him back maybe
not
2007
oh it's going to be echo so 2007 we're
watching like
it's got to be echo
draco's death
and it looks like they are showing us
that
well they
i'll keep quiet let's watch
yeah subtitles so she she's
so she's deaf it seems like she's
she's reading her her lips
are they gonna shoot
me lopez
they don't know she they don't know
she's deaf it's so sad
but she got the right answers anyways
so she's a g she's gonna be a genius
okay and this has to be k bishop oh or
is it her dad
dude are they gonna show kingpin this
episode
kingpin kills her dad in the comics
what sound does the sky make
it's quiet like you
what son does a dragon make
so she's talking with her dad
and she's asking him questions in sign
language
are dragons real
yeah
shengchi
would have learned to come into our
world well shanghai went to their world
i'll be cool i'm a dragon
i thought i was going to school with
kids like me
oh
that's impossible
this is going to be so sad
i love this though this is nice
we could pay for you said we could pay
for the deaf school
she's gonna be a genius
yeah oh that's pretty cool he tied it
back to the dragon
just by watching
that's so sad
oh she's gonna have like the same
upbringing
as kate bishop which is why it's gonna
be so good this is gonna be so cool to
watch
so she's just so she's doing karate now
and she's studying the other kids
she's sitting on the side watching and
studying
this is pretty cool
i love the throwbacks when they do
more about speed than size for karate
meet him up
yeah all right oh dude is that kingpin
is it dutch cake bin
that's kingpin 100
that was kingpin oh my gosh
that was him they didn't do oh that was
so obviously him
wilson
that was 100 him
that was 100 king fan
wow
that looks exactly like her oh and she's
missing a leg
that's different
so she's growing up now and fighting
and she's missing a leg which is
interesting deaf and missing a leg deaf
and missing a leg
that doesn't stop her
no
no that was kingpin wow
they really just did they just went for
it
like a big kingpin too
like very karmic accurate kingpin
we didn't see the face we didn't see the
face i can't tell you if it's dinofrio
or not i don't know if it's that actor
oh
oh she's watching a hot guy oh my gosh
it's not gonna kill her dad
because that would suck
so
so she sees ronan
right now
killing all the like the mobsters and
she's kind of like watching him
oh no that was her dad
oh no
that's a twist that's so sad
that's a twist
i'm already gone
don't give me goosebumps
is this gonna be a tearjerker i mean
some people are probably crying right
now
oh no
oh no
that's so sad
so for those asking where kingpin was he
walked up right behind her dad right
before he left her in the karate part he
walked he was wearing a full black suit
that was him but it was huge you could
tell that was him
kb toys going out of business oh this is
where they're at
they're still
tied up so now we're back to where we
left off
kate bishop and hawkeye are still
writing i don't even know what you call
those
mole toys
go get more quarters
bro
bro i found that
seems like you're mad at me
[Music]
they're like irish
okay
[Laughter]
oh
awkward
did you say i need a pen to write it
down
hawkeye is done
thank you and lauren's still sitting on
these toys
they're not merry-go-rounds there
oh
she will oh i called it
alright so here's echo
echo's about to interact with hawkeye
and kate bishop
oh she sees this hearing aid
so she's gonna know
that he's hard of hearing or
hmm
i'm very
hahaha
you might find
that's funny
you might find you're better off without
the hearing aid
[Laughter]
she's nine she's not ronin she's nine
i'm running say it
because i'm ronin
uh
hawkeye says ronan's dead
black widow killed him
you're a lion
oh
my is about to kill her
echo's about to kill
freaking kate bishop
so echo just wants to kill ronan now
laughs
be stronger
that'll be me
and i'd be running
wait for my signal there's no signal
i wonder like they've gotta re they
gotta find out that he was actually
ronin during the five year gap
eventually
but how was the question well he's gonna
say
i'm sorry i killed your dad he was
working for kingpins organization right
that's going to be the big thing here
and that's when we're going to hear the
name kingpin but that was totally
kingpin which is freaking sweet
oh i called it
100
yes you did we have it on the footage
oh
oh she kicked his hearing aid out with
her bionic leg
i don't know if you guys have ever been
hit in the ears it freaking hurts and it
disorients you oh she's gonna step on it
i knew it you're better off without your
hearing aid
i mean it really throws you off
like not having like it throws off your
balance or equilibrium yeah glass
afterwards
so she has a bow oh it was kate's bow
because he brought his bow
and she brought her bow
so right now they're having a bow fight
whoa
that was impressive
he shot two arrows around her neck and
oh
oh my gosh
so he just hit
shot that guy with an arrow in the ear
is he is he going to be hard to be right
now i'm sensing a theme in this
oh my gosh on a ball pit
oh
not the fee
oh snap is just straight up
oh kate's holding her own
are these dummy arrows he's not actually
killing them i don't think
no he's stabbing him
oh yeah he's stabbing him
oh and she's just wheeled freaking
oh that's cool
oh
this episode is already i feel like so
much better than the others already
because they're in a toy place
my hair yeah right
it's not a merry-go-round what are those
things called i have no idea
oh i respect that i respect that
we're not smashing a 72 challenger
she's all looking at it like
okay i mean i'd want to take it too but
i respect the move i'm not smash as a
car guy i respect it
oh it's not really [ __ ]
oh don't shoot it kate bishop she's a
kid
someone's getting in the challenger
wait who hit that guy on the side
i think oh we're about to get this
awesome scene right here
where she's gonna shoot explosive arrows
smile you're moving trust a bro trust
the bro that's awesome no
not that bro
i love the christmas music oh my gosh
this is this is so much better than the
first step is two episodes for me
it do it kate
we're out of regular arrows
she's so excited
nope not this one
nope too dangerous
they're not be careful they're not
regular arrows
what kind of air did she get explosive
explosive
it's gonna be too close
it's goo
that's pretty good
label your arrows
oh she can't he can't he can't hear
and she doesn't know
the christmas music is pretty sweet
i love it trust the bro i love that
wow she sort of blew it up
oh challenger
no
you think it gets blown up
i don't know i think it gets blown up
it's gonna get some purple goo no it's
not
that's an explosive
oh no
it might have like a detonator or
something
she's sticking out of the car bro you're
gonna she's gonna get hit by something
you're also still a christmas tree
you're also still driving backwards
they take out the ford symbol like we
don't know it's a freaking ford yeah
right
okay i really jump on the christmas
thing
what an arrow
sorry santa
oh
acid arrows hit the stop lights ah
so we can run them i guess
okay because you got to be safe
safety safety first in car chases and
here comes the command the challenger
i just think who thinks of doing that
hawkeye we're learning a lot about
hawkeye
just shoot it with acid arrows
all right
why would you not shoot
why would you not shoot the car
following
you yeah right
why would you
that's her bow
oh
smack him in the head thank you
okay
that works that's their color i know
okay stop driving oh my gosh if you
cannot seek a smoke's in your car
the challenger was total anyways
stop stop stop stop stop stop never
oh but they can show us that that's a
subaru
but not the ford they need it
more than four
oh she's about to blow somebody up
take out that truck
oh he's got an explosive arrow
jesus has a regular one it looks like it
oh my gosh that was pim technologies
how
what
that was awesome those were pin
particles
so those must be what hank pin pink pimp
gave him
so this was like an ant man called this
is another ant-man callback
so he had to get back his plunger arrow
to set off something else
oh this is a classic hawkeye move oh
she's holding to the thing all the way
down to his bow
that's class she's she's screaming she
loves it
oh that's why you got the plunger arrow
oh
this episode is already way better than
the other episodes
a genius fighting another genius
clay you're getting old buddy
that's why she's gonna take on the
hawkeye mantle yo that pim arrow was
sweet
like i gotta walk the dog
you're not wrong
they're just chilling now
walk the
dog
he thinks she's a good shot
roger's a musical
they are diving into the christmas thing
they are diving into it
oh
yeah he's like losing his hearing big
time
doesn't have a head all right
yeah come on
uh oh oh that's her
this is not good because he
he's gonna
people are gonna sneak up on him
well i think he can hear in one ear
[Music]
monkey
everyone's asleep he's his son's calling
him and he can't hear him that's really
sad
no
ugly christmas sweater part oh feel so
bad
do you know this person
not that name what
they know you're alley cat
so it's okay if you can't be home for
christmas oh
that's very sad he can't hear his kids
no
you feel like the punisher bill that's
funny
is she
taller than him
he looks short
it's taller than me i'm sure
trust the bra moving company
okay
so was going to say she thinks ronan
killed her dad but ronan did kill her
dad
but he's working for kingman
so
interesting
she's like naturally pissed off i mean i
guess i would be too my dad was murdered
when i was
this morning kind of got out of hand you
didn't realize how dangerous this is
if we keep going after around and we
were supposedly going
hope uncle won't find out he wouldn't be
happy that is kingpin all day
always put the crew first
remind me who's in charge
i know it
please
it's so
they show kingpin they showed part of
him it's so obviously him and now
uncle
uncle fisk is in charge right
good thing they call you hawkeye not
hawk ear that's funny
oh no she's he said block delete
please
fix this smashed hearing aid
good luck she's a doctor apparently
i mean
i mean there's not really much to show
you guys right now they're just getting
his hearing aid fixed
he can't really hear anything so
so like right now he doesn't hear her
talk so he's just kind of spacing out
he put his hearing aid in and
it works now
yay
i've dreamed of this
being a superhero
comes with a price
interesting trying to anyway
yeah
some people lose he's talking about
natasha
black widow
she's not wrong
your branding issue she's still on this
we gonna get a comic accurate hawkeye
here
[Laughter]
that is the comic accurate hot guy
nice
that's your head
wings
like a hawk
she drew him
that's an h on your head for hawkeye
what if it was all black with a mask
okay but purple
you are running
oh
ghost
i'm not a role model oh come on well as
ronan he did kill a ton of vehicle
yelena i think would be kate i'm just
gonna throw that out there
she's a trained assassin
he's her hero she's not letting him give
up on himself
and then there's a
oof
you're stuck
it's gonna be my excuse when we got to
dinner
my mom canceled my credit card
on an unrelated note on an unrelated
note i forgot my card
lucky
little caesars
it's her dog of pizza
he knows pizza dog
yes she knows
he smiled at pizza dog lucky the pizza
dog
his name is kazi
why i don't want you to do that i just
you kidding me
oh my gosh you're killing me
guys our thing stopped
no why
oh
no is happening hold on we we have
paused
i don't know what happened
play
okay
and not in our ear it's not in our ear
there we go okay sorry we uh
pizza dog
i love christmas music guys it's
december
first
this is a girl who's always cold but i'm
freezing and i am
there's someone above maya
someone you don't want to mess with
that's kingpin
yeah lucky don't get involved like he's
like what do you mean i never knew
no that's
too obvious
oh my gosh
you tried to stab your
mother's fiance in the face
the jack thing
okay
milan took a turn
dance of the sugar plum fairy
all the christmas music
and apparently this is a dance that's a
ballerina
couldn't be me but it's a ballerina
wait
how do you not have a i was gonna say
how do you not have a key in everything
i'll take that home
great great great great grandfather
built the building oh
[Music]
she probably did it to the
to the
song
she
i'm in the wrong business
i'll get on
stabbed with a sword
god
hmm
and i've just been locked out
which means somebody knows
meanwhile checking around the house
oh
don't move
oh
oh it's gonna be the freaking end of the
freaking
come on man it just got exciting
oh
so okay is there a post credit
no okay hold on real fast let's go
through this
let's go through the cast
let's go through the cast do we see
dinofrio
oh
let's see what we got here hold on
okay
no no no you stupid why would you do
that okay hold on
nice teacher karate teacher
cranky pete's what no they don't
bigger karate kid
tom thomas
wait that that's all you're giving me
for the cast
all right i'm about to okay a kid
kidding car
all right that's all they gave me but
here i'm about to bring it back to
i'm about to bring it back to kingpin
right here
that's him touching her cheek
that's literally kingpin touching her
cheek
all right
oh it makes me so sad with their young
and her dad
right here that's king fan entire
oh my gosh that's so obviously kingpin
look at this can you see this
without the glare
look at this look how big this person is
this is so obvious that is so obviously
kingpin
look at that oh my gosh
that was this is so him how do i like
screenshot this
yeah it's black because it doesn't let
me screenshot it and then he touches her
face
oh that's so him that's obviously him
okay
well we have stuff to talk about that
was so awesome
all right well
kingpins here will they actually address
him
in the show it looks like they will but
i mean
it could be the post credit and they
really might not come out and just say
but we know we know
they're not fooling anybody
they we know
all right uh
all right well
we have that we're gonna get kristen
here are you sticking around are you
yeah i can stick around okay
let's
how do i do that
hold on we can't hear you
i mean can you hear me
okay so hold on
we gotta get
chris up in her
hi
i think
i'm not sure people can hear you
actually
talk
i don't think people can hear you
uh
let me see something real quick
okay so but like obviously that was
kingpin i mean like we don't really have
to you know
you know what i'm talking about
i can't hear you now
nope can't hear you at all
this should be you it's not
hello testing test testing test can't
hear you can't tell you they can't hear
you
now i can hear you
but uh
i don't know if the chat can
which doesn't make any sense because we
have literally changed nothing
hey cam k thanks for that super chat
yeah i mean it was undoubtedly
him
um i can hear you but i don't know if my
chat can
hey
we can't hear you
we can't hear you and i don't
oh
why
why does that make any sense
we do it every week why can't we
um
yes it is mine
what the heck okay i don't understand
why this is so freaking hard
right you can hear them through my phone
add a new source
display
is it display capture is how
i display capture
that's okay that's we're just gonna
we're gonna mute this guy and bring this
guy here
talk
what the freak
properties
[Music]
we love audio
i don't understand this like
wes where are you what why the heck
yeah i don't even like
apparently i mean what the heck it is
why is this why like why this doesn't
even make any sense like i i hate
messing with this
i'm not
i'm i'm not getting anything like at all
yeah um
but what the heck this is
we'll see if you can get screenshots
because i can't even screenshot on my
ipad
okay wait a second i might have figured
something out
uh
maybe not hold on
talk
hello i gotcha
yeah but we should have chris
except now i'm talking double again
which is
my youtube channel is gonna hate it lose
the few viewers
well can you mute one of your things i
have it's not
i don't know what it is i hear myself
talking
weird
stupid stupid stupid stupid well just
enjoy your thing i'll do my own thing
and then i'll start screenshotting i'll
figure it out later
well that sucks because
i mean yeah that sucks we were gonna get
brad in here and talk too but oh nobody
told me that
maybe not though i don't know though
no i don't i yeah i don't want to do if
it's crap like you can do it brad if you
want but there's no point me sitting
here talking because the few people that
watch me don't want to listen to it
poorly it's all doubled for you
yeah well alex can't hear you either
wait a second nope yeah it still is
yeah just do your thing we'll figure it
out it's not good
that's lame all right cool
everybody say bye to chris and subscribe
to cosmic culture
right freaking hey we finally got it and
then
wait talk again
it's still echoed on my side
is it yeah they're all saying in my chat
what about now
well it started echoing again when i got
sound on my end
unmute the mic that's causing the echo
oh
you can't you can't go the same source
dang
freaking a well that's dumb okay we'll
figure it out for next week
oh
audio
anyways everyone subscribe to chris
kingpin company
boom
i don't i don't know how to do anything
that's not it
i don't know
you should be able to hear me now you
should be able to hear me now i think i
accidentally turned it off
test test test
test oh my gosh why is this so bad
this doesn't make any sense why okay i
think it should be good now though right
i mean
yeah okay good good good good good good
all right everybody one last time say
goodbye to
miss ally
this is her channel you can go subscribe
to her
uh she's gotta get to work in the
morning but if you subscribe to her
youtube channel and watch her videos
eventually she can just do that for a
living and not have to work in the
morning
and she can stay with us longer go
subscribe
yeah
so
marvel minute news go check her out
everybody say bye bye bye guys thank you
guys for watching
see you later so yeah i'll move the
chair back later if you just want to
scoot it to the side i'll put it back in
your
butt
all right guys what do we got here
oh wait
i i i see you brad lambert
hey hey there he is
you probably can't see me i don't think
you are going to be able to see me
what an episode oh yeah hold on let me
uh
how do i get you there we go
there is a one brad lambert right there
and i'm going to scoot over this way
so people can see me as well so okay
everybody say hi to brad i'm sure
everybody knows who brad is
what's up everyone awesome dude awesome
dude yeah okay so kingpin
[Laughter]
that one thousand percent
was vincent d'onofrio yeah everyone has
already been saying like oh that's his
laugh blah blah blah blah blah like
without question yeah
and the second he like pulled up behind
him i was like oh my gosh that's so
funny because it's so very obvious that
like
that it's him you know what i mean oh
yeah
he was so big he was so big and an uncle
right that's totally kingpin
yeah
they really nailed it with those kind of
descriptions the uncle term
and we saw the suit you know his his
looming presence and then even hawkeye
talking about him as a guy you don't
want to mess with
right yeah i mean it's all
and every and everybody was like
everybody
before this episode i should say
everybody was like oh you know
echo's not the top right it's like yeah
yeah it's she's totally not the top like
man but with that episode i think was
like so above the other episodes
to me
without question it started quick yeah
like on grit
100 miles an hour i i loved it yeah it's
crazy uh for those asking will that be
episode four yes there are six episodes
so we have i can't believe we're halfway
done i know i'm like i'm really sad that
it's only you know
only six and like i know we've had other
ones that were only six
like
how how how many episodes were loki
they're nine right
yeah i thought it was eight or nine how
many were six
was falcons
falcon was only six [ __ ] morally six
yeah all right guys let's get let's get
some going in the chat what do you guys
rate this brad
let's let's start with you but chat rate
it out of 10 what do you what do you
rate this episode actually let's start
off because you weren't here last week
what do you rate the other two episodes
and then what do you rate i thought the
other two episodes were good but this is
definitely above and beyond better than
the last two
i would definitely agree
yeah i mean i i'd give it a nine like it
was very well done a nine because you
gotta you gotta leave some room for what
yeah
i know it's gonna get better from here
let's be honest
for sure for sure so
i i'm i'm seeing a lot of nines eight
eight five nine ten
nine eight eight eight eight seven seven
seven seven i don't know if you're
looking at my stream brad every once in
a while yeah
okay just making sure
yeah there's a i mean hi
well with kingpin i mean that's pretty
like
i mean the first episode is like there
were so many connections to him
and i just think
you know
how could they not especially they did
change her origin though right because
in the origin
fisk actually kills her dad
so this is actually i actually thought
this was a really cool twist
i agree
so it's just kind of like
so what happens like
does hawkeye
does she forgive hawkeye some somehow
right uh how is the
because like
he's not he's not gonna die right let's
just i mean i mean
is he would they do that the guy with
the family right like
look all i'm saying is they're they're
teeing it up as a possibility i think
it's a possibility i think they may want
us to think that he could die i mean
they killed iron man
i mean look who had a little girl at the
time so you're introducing
kay bishop right
yeah
i mean i i just i don't know like what
brenner's future is unless he retires
you know like he did before
but i like i really like this episode
pulled on my heart strings a lot
especially with his hearing and him not
being able to communicate with his kids
like
and all the like ptsd and trauma from
his days of ronan
like i don't know man i really left this
episode like
i don't know maybe maybe he's not gonna
make it out of this like
i don't know can y'all
what do y'all think of that do y'all
think chat i'm talking to y'all
do
you how would you feel if hawkeye dies
at the end of this and then kate that's
how kate takes over you know she swears
the hawkeye mantle
you know for clint and everything like
that um
stephen thanks for the super chat was
that a hand ninja who killed her dad
ordered by fisk
i i think it was ronin he he you know
he he
hawkeye knew a lot he talked about you
know there's someone above her you don't
want to mess with him uh
and he even said i took care of what did
he say like upper management or
something like that yeah he took care of
upper management with the tracksuit game
yeah
yeah so
i mean there are just too many things
happening in this show you have echo who
wants revenge right right i mean and
then kingpin who wants revenge on
hawkeye and then elena wants revenge
because she thinks i kill widow so tal
zanko thanks for the super chat yeah you
linda how will elena come into this brad
just mentioned like you know she wants
revenge because
he killed her sister right in her mind
because yeah val out there yeah vows
manipulating lies yep yeah so i mean
oh
man i mean he could you're not wrong
yeah i mean
i i just feel like with everything you
know i don't know i feel like he's gonna
like leave it out on the field if you
know what i mean
i i get that yeah totally i'm just
wondering
so here's like the here's like the weird
thing where it's like oh it's disney
they're not gonna like do that but at
the same time like it is still marvel
studios and it is still real writers and
it is still filmmakers right and there
is still storytelling and it's not like
people don't die in disney you know what
i'm saying it's like i mean in this
episode we saw ronin carving people up
and blood splattering on the windows and
stuff like that
the mcu is maturing it's getting
grittier it's getting darker and you
have to especially when you have moon
night coming right you have the
potential daredevil rumors and kingpin
and everything surrounding that
i just like and they're talking
multiverse madness is going to be a
horror film right like
the mcu is maturing so like i i don't
see
that as a stretch
if he survives will i be survived or
will i be surprised no but i will think
that like from a character development
standpoint him leaving it out there and
and sacrificing himself to save kate
bishop or her learning what it means to
be hawkeye from a sacrificial standpoint
you know he talked about all the
sacrifices and things you lose
oh cool costume
like that's a wake-up call you know jeez
so i i think that would be a really cool
character development for kate if if
hawkeye dies in the show yeah well now
i'm kind of like oh crap is he gonna die
like
now
i went from not thinking he was gonna
die oh crap is this guy gonna die oh man
i saw you
he
he might you're not wrong he
i hope he doesn't i'll see him he's so
innocent with it man like she's she's
out there having fun she's playing like
dress up like she she doesn't get the
ramifications that he's talking about
yeah and he's even like saying like oh
you're over confidence blah blah blah
blah and yeah she's
oh
that's interesting bradley jones super
chat hope they don't kill him would be
so messed up right before christmas he
promised his family he'd be home that
would
that would definitely add to it like he
tells his family he's gonna be home and
then he dies oh man
that's um
that's some tough stuff right there
uh thanks cam kevin super chat we're
gonna get a rock paper scissors with
echo going after elena based off what
haka said and yolanda going after
hawkeye
and h going for echo i mean yeah at this
point in time it's like i'm wondering
how
i'm wondering how truth is gonna come
out
the truth that hot guy is ronin right um
that he killed that he was the one who
killed echo because you know she's
telling uh cause ghazi will do some you
know investigating on on clint you know
yeah but no one knows clint was ronin no
i don't think i don't know if anyone
knows it does his wife know it you know
what i mean like
well yeah
she was
she was gone
right so it was gone so does i don't
know if anybody does know it he might
have told her like yeah when you were
gone i was in a very low place just so
you know i killed every player
i killed a lot of people killing play
they were bad people but like as we saw
here and this is actually gonna have to
be something that like
clint deals with
yes echo's dad
like worked for a bad organization but
he he wasn't a bad guy he almost had
like no choice right
you know he was trying to provide for
his little girl who was deaf and like we
it was very clear in the beginning he
couldn't afford to send her to a deaf
school right i mean yo they gave her uh
i want to say bionic legs i don't know
what else to call it
a metal leg you know
prosthetically prosthetic yeah yeah
that's different i i love the
inclusivity of this like what marvel's
doing with makari and eternals and now
with echo like it's very cool it's very
cool oh for sure for sure and alec will
cox shout out to her brilliant
performance in this episode yeah for
sure
um
this was really a good episode and i
love the kingpin tease and this is uh
alex style thanks super chat yeah the
team panties was crazy it would have
been a dead giveaway if he was wearing a
white suit yeah but i mean like
it was still the same
yeah i mean it i mean he didn't wear the
white suit every time in daredevil
either so yeah you know i i mean it was
it was the laugh and and the looming
presence of of kingpin and
he's got a purchase avengers tower right
oh man right you would i'm just like
thinking about that too like
oh man well okay so like
do you talk about his looming presence
like the second he came in i was like
that's freaking kingpin
and that was what the first like
two minutes yeah three months like hold
on i'm
five minutes but that's not including
the recap right so yeah probably like
the first few minutes and it even says
like i have the subtitles here right now
like oh cool we'll take you home right
yeah
oh my gosh he's i'm just like
re-watching he's so big like it's it's
undoubtedly him
and like
really kudos to marvel for like teasing
us and not taking us all the way in a
lot of things in their disney plush
shows
so so when when kate bishop held out the
notepad and it says says uh says it's
okay if you can't make it home for
christmas
yeah
oh crap yeah oh no oh no oh dude i i was
i was like that is heavy man
i don't think he's gonna die i think i
think they very well could kill him i
think i think it could go either way i
do think that but i'm gonna go with my
gut and say that i think your gut's
telling you he's gonna die
yeah i don't know like clint
clint
thought this was gonna be a quick fix
right right and now it's another day and
another day and he's missing all these
things for christmas
and like when he was looking at the
notepad like to me his emotion whether
it was intentional or not was him kind
of like
i don't think i'm gonna make it home for
christmas type [ __ ] right no you're not
that's my opinion i i don't know by the
way do you like the no way home drink
yes i see that yes let's go it's super
awesome shout out to a hot topic hey
there you go i gotta have to check that
out there's one right by my house well
here's an interesting thought king jay
underscore two thanks for super chat
what if kingpin hires someone to dress
as ronan to kill her dad because in
daredevil season three spoiler alert uh
kingpin uses bullseye to be double to
kill which is
like i think is that would be a cool way
to bring it around to where he's kind of
like yeah i didn't kill your dad like i
killed a lot of bad people but i made
sure to like leave the innocent people
because that could be a very like hot
guy thing to do because he clearly was
after the bad guys right
i mean he didn't just go on a killing
spree to kill anybody you know he was
very clearly
and it sounds like he's
it sounds like he's knowledgeable
yeah i don't know man like looking back
at it end game when they were doing like
the the recap of like him taking out the
yakuza and stuff like that like he
wasn't letting anybody leave like
so i i don't know i think that would be
an interesting twist but at the same
time like
i don't know what benefit that would
have because it her father wasn't like
high up in the organization so
well i'm trying i'm like thinking like
because he's he was like
it seems to be like he was like an
accountant or something for them right
yeah
right so you know
it and he's definitely not somebody that
would fight back against him i don't
think
you know no and we just talked about how
he didn't have money to send her to a
good school right so it's not like he
held a high position of power where he
was you know making that money where he
was a threat or a problem for kingpin
um oh man but
that episode
wow
well here's another interesting thought
elle yaki one thing's super chat
blackwood is death loses some meaning if
clinton dies she sacrificed herself so
clint could be reunited with his family
i mean he was reunited with his family
and he got some time and he helped the
avengers and
uh
i get what you're saying and i don't
want him to die
but i after hearing what brad has had to
say there is a chance that he could die
like there there
there really is
well first off black widow did what she
did to bring everybody back right yeah
yeah
yeah that's why she did what she did it
wasn't to just like
save clint right so you know it just
happened to be clint yeah i mean it just
so happened to be and she had her own
reasons right she was ready to go out as
a hero and end it all type stuff so
i don't know man like you know the the
health
uh decline of clint
is you know from a hearing standpoint
and like man like i cannot believe how
they fully embraced how he lost like
could not hear once she smashed his
hearing aid like i'd love that like i
thought that was really cool and
powerful and uh you know the jokes
between the two of them they should have
called you hawkier like
so i i guess he's completely deaf in one
ear and the hearing helps the other ear
right he's only got one good ear with a
hearing air and they tied that back to
the explosion at the compound right yeah
which i really liked yeah i i love that
i like i love how he's all sarcastic
it's like it's hard to tell like
what what happened it's hard to tell
like all these crazy things years of an
event being an avenger uh baron zimba
thanks for super chat here's a good
thought
because i've heard people talking about
this do you think fans of daredevil show
will be disappointed
do you think this kingpin is connected
to the show or is completely new uh i
don't think anything's gonna be
connected to the netflix shows at all i
don't think there's gonna be any new
connection i hope it's
no frio um
you know i hope it's the same one i hope
it's uh
i always call him that i always switch
up matt murdock with charlie cox i'm
always like yeah charlie [ __ ] daredevil
like oh no no hold on
uh i i think charlie cox is coming back
it's daredevil but i don't think they're
connected
like
at all but i mean like when when he
laughed that was that was him right yeah
i think it's going to be totally new
stories but i think it's going to be the
you know i think matt murdock's going to
know who kingpin is just like hawkeye
does you know so
i'm excited to see the mcu's take on
this and i love that they're bringing
these guys back oh for sure i think it's
really really cool now the question is
i haven't heard anything about this as
far as i'm concerned daredevil matt
murdock's first appearance will be no
way home i wonder if they i wonder if
they hint to daredevil on this because
daredevil and echo get together right
and yaku gets her own show which
obviously kingpin is going to be in the
show that's been rumored for a while
that's obviously confirmed now and so
obviously the rumor that daredevil is
going to be in the show is probably
confirmed now with this as well because
the reports are coming from the same
people right so
but i also love once again
touching on like when when clint
couldn't hear
like that gave me
heavy daredevil like
matt in his house
like
it just made me think of the the
daredevil show and i was like wow okay
this episode
it did because it's more gritty when he
was just showed ronin killing everybody
and you know stuff like that that
because that was like my talk last week
is i don't think this show is gonna be
nearly as gritty as like the netflix
shows were like
they were brutal sometimes yeah they
were dark and i don't think we're going
dark especially like with the you know
they're blowing up cars to christmas
music
it's funny and i i really liked it and i
think it's really cool now here's a good
thought as well storm frantic thanks to
super chat jack could be blamed as ronin
because he has a sword now maybe he'll
be killed because of it i so
that is a possibility and i just want to
bring up the fact that i don't really
know if jack is evil
because i feel like it's they're trying
to make it so in your face that it's
just not because it's too in my face
yeah it it that's fair you know what i'm
saying like
he's definitely up to something let's
put it down oh for sure for sure but i
think uh eleanor killed
uh
is it arnold i can't remember zane
armond um i think eleanor probably
killed him i mean the swords are all
over her penthouse right i think it's
just too obvious oh the swordsman killed
him with the sword right it's like
really like i i that's classic
misdirection right yeah trying to hit
you with it and i just think it's
classic-based direction vera for amiga
though like she's got to be bad in this
show right that's what i'm saying i
think she i think it's her i think alan
yes him
she's got to be some deal they were
clearly fighting before right and she's
like did he threaten you i'm like i
think she threatened him
you know what i'm saying and i think she
pulled through on the threat
by snapping him
can we talk about the
awesome combat in this episode like
hawkeye shiny like
i was really impressed like it was very
cool the pin arrow like dude oh my gosh
that was so cool he pulled it out and
said pin and i'm like oh step but then
like i didn't catch on at first
obviously right and then when they did
it i was like
that's so cool oh they they crushed it
when when they were doing the car chase
i was thinking about ant-man and the
wasp yeah and i literally said it on
stream i was like
the music and the the comedy and the
vibes of the trick arrows and stuff i
was like this makes me feel like ant-man
and then five minutes later they did the
the pim arrow and i was like wow
well
yeah i didn't think about that but
totally totally totally now here's a
cool uh sword the user sort of my chat
here's a pretty cool thought and i
thought this when i saw it it says or
she says maya lopez dad knows about
tallow and i'm like yeah like i think
he's like
it really does seem like
he knows about tylo um
he is he indigenous
or is he like native american or was he
asian i couldn't tell
uh i couldn't tell either um
i i i'm not sure because if he's asian
then maybe there is some type of
connection there or maybe even like the
indigenous people know like because that
was but yeah but i i wouldn't rule out
that he knows about tala no it i think
he it sounds like he does yeah it was
pretty convincing yeah are dragons real
yeah oh maybe in another you know in a
different way right it's like okay
you're 100 correct they had to travel to
a different realm to like
go you know and i'm thinking
the way city she asked that i was like
yeah that's shanghai you know it was all
about dragons and then i i realized like
well they did have to go to like a
different like realm and they even say
like oh in this world or in your world
like so there's very clear like line
between the worlds uh where tallow is
and i thought that was uh
that was pretty cool
i like how they're tying the stuff in
i'm ready to see
just so much more all these are like so
good and they're disney plush shows and
the movies are starting to be insanely
huge spider-man nelly home is to be
ridiculous probably the biggest movie of
all time it'll probably be in game and
in avatar
i it it's going to be up there let's put
it that way
so okay i just kind of had a thought
to paddle back you know so
in the comics
jack
jacquez
um is his name in the comics you know he
gets mentored by hawkeye
um or no he he mentors hot guys sorry he
mentors hawkeye and teaches him you know
all this stuff
i'm starting to wonder
maybe he maybe he maybe he did do some
damn because he was like bad and then he
became good and maybe that's the same
thing here like he was bad and he became
good maybe he did do some damage maybe
that was him that killed
her dad right maybe
maybe it wasn't actually i'll have to go
back and like take it let me take a look
right now like how obvious is it that
it's ronin or
is it just kind of like a ninja outfit
right it i'm watching it right now let
me take a look like i wonder is it
clearly hawkeye here or is it clearly
ronin here
uh well that part where he stabs her dad
it's kind of hard to tell
huh
[Music]
yeah it looks like him
yeah i mean i i thought it was him but i
i mean who knows
kate bishop was running because she was
wearing the costume so exactly right so
anyone can wear the suit we actually
don't know yeah right
um does it actually say though
what time
does it say what time period this is
like when we get to no i don't think it
i don't think it says yeah
i don't think it's specified so i mean
clearly this underground
yo okay so check this out yeah yeah so
like in the comics kingpin is like a big
part of that auction that's in madrid
they obviously switched that here so
kingpin's people were looking for
the watch i guess they weren't looking
for the caution but somehow it ended up
in this underground
auction right yeah which means you know
hawkeye didn't have it the avengers
didn't have it right so i mean somebody
else like this could have happened
during that time period where hawkeye
didn't have the ronin suit
yeah you know it could be but why why do
they want
the watch that's like who's watching it
well
oh my gosh
no way
the freaking place
their headquarters at this time is
called fat man auto repair come on
come on guys come on that's king like
that's like the
fat man auto repair i just noticed that
that's funny
that's funny
so yeah who knows man i mean jack is
swordsman in the comics he he starts off
bad becomes good
uh
he trains hawkeye now i don't think
that's the case here because
i don't know if hawkeye joined the
circus and the mcu in the beginning has
the whole origin story there
um and jeremy render is older than tony
dalton so i don't know yeah i don't yeah
i don't think that'll be connected in
this one no so that's gonna be
weird but the watch the watch is a
mystery to me right now i'm wondering
whose watch that is what well remember
the the
tracksuit gang they were hired to go get
the watch right exactly
so that's where i'm like if they're
following orders from kingpin
why would he want the watch was kingping
maybe
at the compound for something you know
well maybe the watch yo what if he
purchased avengers tower and maybe the
watch
open something or connects to something
i don't know maybe
that's that's so the watch and yelena
are my biggest kind of questions yes
right now because when does she come in
slash
do they really tease her to come in the
hawkeye and her not show up in hot guy
no she's got to be in she's got it right
i mean she has to right that's just it's
just all i'm thinking is it's a lot so
the fact that elena's coming in makes me
think that we're not really gonna get
the big kingpin introduction until
either the very last episode where they
just kind of say like yeah
the person behind all of it is his name
is kingpin or like he's a kingpin or you
know what i mean or they say yes or
something like that maybe the post
credit we see him but i don't think he's
going to be a prominent character
in this coming up maybe who knows but
that just seems like a lot yelena echo
kingpin
and then well elena could be very
temporary you know she could pop in for
one episode and then
dip once she realizes that
he didn't kill her you know what
what if she
what if she just goes to visit his
family what if she just goes straight to
and then he gets home and she's there
and then kills him
oh gosh you really wanted to die
oh man yeah who knows
who
i mean man can you imagine like what if
he's like walking up to his house and
just like arrow like oh dude that would
be
oh
man
that would
that would be intense
wow
yeah that that was savage warren
i mean
she's kind of savage
uh yeah
like
no remorse yeah
dang
well all right well that was an awesome
episode i gotta get started my breakdown
because i'm gonna be up for hours upon
hours but uh that's appreciated
again yeah same time to you man
appreciate you chat have a good night
everybody say bye to brad and we're
gonna do this again
next week see you guys appreciate you
guys have a good one bye bye
all right well
that was hawkeye that was the best
episode we've had a hot guy so far and
wow
wow we need owen wilson back up in here
geez that's um
i don't want hot guy to die
i really don't want him that i hope he
walks out of this
alive like i i really don't want hot guy
to die i don't i don't think he will
i don't think he will oh the watch
belongs to dr strange that's your first
thought
alex wilson not a bad thought i would
just question how that ended up in the
avengers compound you know
who knows
he did have all those watches but i
think he like sold them all right i
think he sold all his watches like to
try to fix his hands and stuff like that
i don't think he had really many
possessions left after that but hey
three episodes left this was by far the
best episode out of the first two uh
well first three i guess and um wow i i
i really enjoyed this episode i'm not
gonna lie the first two didn't really
like like i i was like grabbed i was
like yeah i like you know
i don't dislike the show by any means
but i was just kind of like yeah this is
fun like it's a fun show like yeah yeah
yeah like it's really really nice and um
um
but now i'm like wow this is actually
like getting really really good there's
a freaking kingpin in there like oh man
i can't believe they did that that's so
awesome guys that's so
awesome that they put kingpin
oh gosh it's so cool like i didn't think
it was going to come out so fast but
that was clearly kingpin and it sounded
like daniel freya's laughed so
dang all right gotta have to get started
on my breakdown
expect that out uh sometime in the
morning um and we're gonna be
right back here next week same time
about uh 11
20 11 30 um
p.m pacific time california time um i'm
really
i'm really liking i'm really really
liking the show and this i think i feel
like this one uh
this one really stepped it up and i
think it's gonna be a good final three
episodes i think a lot's about to happen
actually i think a lot's about to happen
so hey i love you all thanks so much for
stopping by today whether you were
chatting super chatting sitting in the
background just listening appreciate you
all so much
a lot of exciting stuff is happening
right now and it's a great time to uh
to be fans it really really is i
appreciate you all oh hey real quick i'm
doing a really big giveaway in december
until the end of the year i'm going to
come out with a video kind of showing
everything i'm going to be giving away
i'm basically going to go buy a whole
entire uh store full of collectibles um
buy everything in it like mr b style so
that's gonna come within the next few
days
uh explaining how to enter and
everything like that so keep looking for
that and uh look out for my video coming
in the morning breaking down this
episode of hawkeye which i'm excited to
do because it was really cool episode so
all right love you all 3000 i'll catch
y'all next time woof